bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui on va parler de Thomas Coon
Thomas Coon est un philosophe des
sciences né en 1922
il est connu pour son ouvrage la
structure des révolutions scientifiques
publiées en 1962 un ouvrage qui a fait
date dans la philosophie des sciences
contemporaines un ouvrage qui a fait
date parce que Kun il propose une vision
de la science assez originale
une vision qui va un peu à l'encontre
des préjugés qui entourent la science et
qu'on va tenter de comprendre
aujourd'hui
et pour la comprendre je vais partir
d'une phrase qu'on entend parfois qui
est comme une sorte d'adache populaire
qui dit tout est une question de
perception
alors tout est une question de
perception ça veut dire plusieurs choses
ça veut dire d'abord qu'on n'a pas tous
la même perception des choses
par exemple on n'a pas tous la même
perception du bien et du mal
on n'a pas tous la même perception de
l'amour de l'amitié de la réussite
et quand on parle de perception ici on
parle en fait de représentation
la perception ça regroupe la sensibilité
le tempérament les croyances
et donc tout ça influe sur notre
perception des choses
sur notre perception du monde ou de
nous-mêmes
maintenant si on va un peu plus loin
tout est une question de perception ça
veut aussi dire que nos jugements
proviennent de notre perception
c'est très important ça comprendre en
quoi nos jugements en quoi nos idées
sont conditionnées par notre perception
et qu'un désaccord dans les idées très
souvent comme origine profonde une
différence de représentation
quand on parle politique et qu'on
s'échappe sur des idées politiques
on s'échappe sur des différences de
représentation
sur des différences de sensibilité
on va être sensible à la condition des
travailleurs on va être sensible à la
sécurité
à la liberté d'entreprendre
ce n'est pas juste une question de
connaissance sur le sujet
alors oui bien sûr notre niveau de
connaissance joue sur nos
représentations
mais on peut être très bien informé sur
un sujet et malgré tout ne pas partager
la vision de quelqu'un d'autre qui saura
tout aussi bien informé sur ce sujet
il n'y a pas les biens informés d'un
côté et les mâles informés de l'autre
il y a les sensibles à tels problèmes et
les sensibles à tel autre problème
c'est une question perception
d'ailleurs quand on dit qu'on a évolué
sur tel ou tel sujet
évoluer au sens sous nos opinions ont
changé ou nos idées ont changé c'est
aussi parce que notre perception évolue
on va avoir une opinion sur un sujet
on va rencontrer quelqu'un qui va nous
sensibiliser à son point de vue
sensibiliser ça veut bien dire rendre
sensible
et c'est alors que va s'amorcer le
changement notre opinion
quand nos opinions changent c'est que
notre perception a changé
comme quand Spinoza disait qu'on ne
désirait pas une chose parce qu'on a
trouvé bonne mais qu'on la trouvait
bonne parce qu'on la désirait
pour Spinoza ce n'est pas la pensée qui
conditionne la perception c'est la
perception qui conditionne la pensée
raison pour laquelle les débats sont
très souvent stériles
quand on débat on cherche à plaquer sur
une perception des idées qui sont le
résultat du nôtre perception
un débat ça consiste à vouloir
convaincre l'autre de nos conclusions
sans essayer de le convaincre sur nos
prémices
c'est compliqué
et donc tout est une question de
perception Thomas Coon nous dit ça
s'applique aussi en science
la science aussi fonctionne sur de la
perception
et alors là évidemment la première
réaction c'est de se dire et enfin
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette histoire
en quoi la science est-elle une affaire
de perception
la science cet objectif
c'est neutre
on utilise des instruments de mesure on
utilise des calculs mathématiques
justement pour éliminer tout ce qui
relève de la perception subjective
et puis quand un phénomène se produit
tout le monde perçoit la même chose
quand une cuillère tombe par terre tout
le monde est d'accord pour dire une
cuillère tombe par terre
quel que soit notre perception de la
cuillère
quel que soit la perception associée au
fait de tomber
on va tous une cuillère en train de
tomber
donc qu'est-ce que la perception vient
faire là-dedans
et bien justement
tout est là
pour Koon c'est la science est également
une affaire de perception
c'est parce que pour lui toute recherche
scientifique repose sur une certaine
vision du monde
et que dans l'histoire
les scientifiques n'ont pas toujours eu
la même vision du monde
et cette vision du monde c'est ce que
Thomas Coon appelle un paradigme
un paradigme c'est un mode de
représentation de la réalité
un mode de représentation de la réalité
qui fait que placer face à un même
phénomène on ne va littéralement pas
voir la même chose
j'insiste bien sur le verbe voir parce
que c'est celui qui utilise Kun
il nous dit bien d'un paradigme à
l'autre c'est toute la vision du monde
qui change
on perçoit pas la même chose
est-ce qu'on appelle couramment la
science c'est la production de
connaissances dans le cadre d'un
paradigme
en l'occurrence du paradigme dominant
je vais vous donner un exemple qui n'a
rien à voir avec la science juste pour
vous faire comprendre cette idée de
paradigme
depuis la Révolution française l'un des
principes fondateurs de la République
c'est la liberté
la liberté individuelle
c'est cette liberté individuelle qui
fait que vous pouvez vous habiller comme
vous voulez que vous pouvez vous marier
avec qui vous voulez
ou que vous pouvez pratiquer la religion
que vous voulez
la liberté individuelle est un droit
fondamental
et si on vous en prive vous n'allez pas
être content
parce que vous avez intériorisé ce
principe de liberté
maintenant qu'est-ce qu'il en est de ce
principe de libertin individuelle par
exemple en Chine
en Chine c'est pas pareil
en Chine on n'a pas le même rapport à la
liberté individuelle
on n'a pas la même perception
parce que la culture est différente
parce que l'histoire est différente
et donc ce qui nous paraît normal ici ne
paraîtra pas forcément normal un chinois
en Chine il y a d'autres principes
fondamentaux
par exemple la participation à l'effort
collectif
l'idée que les actions individuelles
participent à l'harmonie du tout
ce ne sont pas des clichés ce sont des
héritages culturels
alors évidemment avec la mondialisation
tout ça tant un peu à somogénéiser
les particularismes culturels tendent à
s'estomper
mais l'idée est là
et l'idée c'est que selon le paradigme
culturel dans lequel vous naissez ou
évoluer vous n'allez pas avoir la même
perception des choses
en Chine les longues discussions à la
machine à café vous enverrai pas
beaucoup
parce qu'ils ont pas le temps
parce qu'il privilégie l'efficacité
on peut appeler ça de la soumission au
grand capital mais la soumission au
grand capital c'est une notion issue de
notre paradigme
la liberté l'égalité la laïcité
c'est notre paradigme à nous
c'est notre univers à nous
bien ce que nous dit cool c'est qu'en
science aussi il y a des univers
en sciences aussi il y a des systèmes de
représentation
et ces systèmes de représentation font
qu'on ne verra pas le monde de la même
façon selon le paradigme dans lequel on
se situe
la signification qu'on va donner à un
fait elle va dépendre de la perception
qu'on a de ce fait
et on n'a pas tous la même perception
d'un fait
le titre est clairement il dit l'effet
sont chargés de théorie
ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que quand vous assistez à
un phénomène vous allez l'interpréter à
partir du référentiel dans lequel vous
vous situez
mais quelqu'un qui se situe dans un
autre paradigme pas pouvoir
l'interpréter autrement
Kun va encore plus loin pour lui
l'effet n'existe pas
les faits n'existent pas au sens où il
n'existe pas sans un cadre
paradigmatique à l'intérieur duquel ils
prennent sens
ce ne sont pas les faits qui créent les
paradigmes ce sont les paradigmes qui
créent les faits
voici une image
que voyez-vous sur cette image
dites le moi en commentaire
il y a deux possibilités
soit vous voyez un canard
soit vous voyez un lapin
peut-être que vous voyez les deux mais
qu'est-ce que vous avez vu en premier
est-ce que vous avez vu le lapin ou
est-ce que vous avez vu le canard
le lapin canard c'est une image qui
illustre ce qu'est un paradigme
parce que c'est une image qui illustre
la différence de perception
et l'impossibilité pour une perception
d'être en même temps une chose et une
autre
vous pouvez voir le canard puis le lapin
ou le lapin puis le canard
successivement
mais pas simultanément
si vous êtes dans le paradigme canard
vous êtes obligé d'en sortir pour voir
le lapin
et inversement
parce que le lapin canard ce ne sont pas
deux images
c'est une seule et même image c'est un
seul et même fait mais sur lequel
peuvent se plaquer de perception
radicalement différentes
et si on vous demandait de délimiter la
partie qui représente le lapin et la
partie qui représente le canard vous
seriez bien embêté
parce que les parties se superposent
parce que les parties se confondent
il n'y a pas une partie lapin et une
partie canard
il y a les deux en même temps
tout est une question de perception
Thomas Cook fait une analyse
philosophique de l'histoire des sciences
et il essaye de comprendre comment
fonctionne la recherche en sciences
c'est intéressant
parce que ça témoigne d'une volonté de
remettre en perspective la science
de ne pas en faire un absolu
de ne pas en faire un dogme
et sa conclusion c'est que la science
n'est pas un processus d'accumulation du
savoir comme on pourrait le croire mais
qu'elle est un processus de passage d'un
paradigme à un autre
et que les savoirs qu'elle produit n'ont
de sens et de valeur qu'à l'intérieur de
ce paradigme
autrement dit la science n'est pas
quelque chose qui est la science est
quelque chose qui devient
elle est un renversement permanent
d'elle-même
une révolution permanente
donc là je sais pas si vous vous en
rendez compte mais ce que fait Thomas
schoon c'est quand même pas rien
il introduit la notion de relativité des
savoirs scientifiques
et oui parce que si la science se
caractérise par le passage incessant
d'un paradigme à un autre ça veut dire
que de même que ce qui était vrai hier
les plus vrais aujourd'hui ce qui est
vrai aujourd'hui ne sera plus vrai
demain
mais ça c'est un problème
dans la formulation même de cette phrase
il y a un problème
parce que comment une chose vraie
pourrait ne plus être vrai
le vrai il est vrai tout le temps
sinon il n'est pas le vrai
donc quand on dit qu'une chose est vrai
ça ne devrait pas seulement être le cas
dans le contexte où on le dit
la vérité n'est pas circonstancielle
sinon elle n'est pas une vérité
sinon elle est une croyance
seulement une croyance
une croyance collective une croyance
généralisée certes mais une croyance
quand même
alors qu'au ne parle pas directement de
croyance ou tout du moins ce n'est pas
cette notion qu'il met en avant
il préfère parler de vision
un paradigme c'est une vision du monde
parler uniquement de croyances ce serait
réducteur
parce que ce serait sous-entendre qu'un
paradigme n'est qu'une affaire d'idées
alors que non
un paradigme c'est aussi une affaire de
perception
une affaire sensorielle
et puis il y a aussi que quand on parle
de croyance on induit l'idée que ce
serait quelque chose de faux
en tout cas que ce serait quelque chose
qu'on aurait tort de croire
un peu comme quand Platon explique que
la croyance et ce qui nous éloigne de la
connaissance
mais en fait non
une croyance n'est ni vrai ni faux en
soi
elle est vraie dans un certain paradigme
et elle est fausse dans un autre
paradigme
elle est vraie du point de vue d'un
certain mode de perception de la réalité
et elle est fausse du point de vue d'un
autre mode de perception de la réalité
vous voyez la différence
c'est ça la relativité des savoirs
un savoir est vrai en tant qu'il
s'insère de façon cohérente dans son
cadre paradigmatique
alors il va quand même falloir qu'on
donne quelques exemples de paradigme
scientifiques pour illustrer tout ça
parce que sinon ça risque de vous
paraître un peu abstrait
exemple de paradigme l'évolution
pourquoi c'est un paradis
parce qu'avant que l'idée d'évolution ne
soit introduite en sciences je parle ici
de l'évolution biologique l'évolution
biologique des espèces avant que cette
idée ne soit introduite on avait une
vision fixiste du monde
fixiste ça veut dire qu'on ne concevait
pas qu'on envisageait pas que la nature
soit en mouvement
et que les espèces vivantes elles-mêmes
alors il y a eu des théories mobilistes
de la nature dans l'Antiquité par
exemple chez des mots-crites
le mobilisme c'est le précurseur
philosophique de l'évolutionnisme
mais ces théories sont restées
minoritaires et de ce fait elles n'ont
pas entraîné un changement de paradigme
donc jusqu'au 18e siècle l'idée d'une
évolution des espèces était totalement
inaudible
d'autant qu'elle se heurte et à la
vision chrétienne à la vision
créationniste
qui énonce que l’homme a été créé à
l'image de Dieu et que donc l'homme ne
peut pas être le fruit d'une évolution
donc quand la marque a commencé à parler
d'évolution des espèces vivantes ce
qu'on appelait alors le transformisme
vous imaginez bien que la marque on l'a
regardé de travers
on l'a regardé comme un fou
parce qu'il faut être fou pour faire
reposer une théorie scientifique sur un
renversement complet de tous les savoirs
établis
quand une théorie contredit tout ce
qu'on sait qu'est-ce qui est le plus
probable
que tout ce qu'on pensait savoir était
faux ou que c'est cette nouvelle théorie
qui est fausse
bien une révolution scientifique c'est
quand une théorie nouvelle contredit les
savoirs établis mais que ça confirmation
oblige à remplacer l'ancien paradigme au
profit d'un nouveau
et pour ce qui est de l'évolution ce
sont les découvertes de Darwin qui vont
obliger la communauté scientifique
à changer de paradigme
autre exemple de paradigme
l'héliocentrisme
les lyocentrisme c'est-à-dire l'idée
selon laquelle c'est la terre qui tourne
autour du soleil et non pas l'inverse
l'inverse étant le géocentrisme
donc là on parlera par exemple de
Jordano Bruno au 16e siècle
Jordano Bruno qui a quand même fini sur
le bûcher pour avoir soutenu ces thèses
héliocentristes avec un peu trop
d'insistance
parce que le monde n'était pas prêt
donc heureusement il y aura Copernic il
y aura Kepler Galilée pour confirmer les
thèses de Jordano Bruno parce que sinon
pas sûr que le changement de paradigme
ce serait produit
et donc en Kun dit que lorsqu'on change
de paradigme c'est toute la vision du
monde qui change il faut le prendre au
sens littéral du mot vision
on ne voit plus la même chose
la réalité reste la même mais la
perception de cette réalité n'est plus
du tout la même
en clair après un changement de
paradigme
on ne vit plus dans le même monde
Kun prend un exemple
quand Aristote regardait un pendule se
balançait
et quand Galilée regardait un pendule se
en réalité il ne voyait pas la même
chose
alors il voyait la même chose au sens où
matériellement c'est le même phénomène
mais visuellement sensoriellement ce
n'est pas le même phénomène
Thomas Cook nous dit que quand Aristote
regarde un pendule il voyait un corps
entravait dans sa chute
le mouvement de balancier c'était pour
Aristote l'effet d'une chute qui
n'arrive pas à s'effectuer
alors que quand Galilée regardez un
pendule
il voyait un corps qui persévère dans
son mouvement
il voyait un corps doté d'une force
dynamique
et ça ça change tout
c'est comme si je vous disais que quand
vous voyez les branches d'un arbre se
plier sous l'effet du vent en fait c'est
pas le vent
c'est l'arbre qui danse
bon ben vous aurez beau dire que
matériellement il s'agit d'un seul et
même phénomène en réalité ça change tout
et pour en revenir à la différence entre
Aristote et Galilée ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que le paradigme de
Galilée n'est pas simplement une
amélioration du paradigme d'Aristote
c'est un dépassement du paradigme
d'Aristote
de même que l'électricité n'est pas une
amélioration de la bougie
c'est un nouveau rapport à la lumière
et c'est ce qui fait dire à cool que
l'une des caractéristiques des
paradigmes c'est l'heure
incommensurabilité
incommensurable ça veut dire qui n'a
littéralement aucun rapport
qui est tellement différent tellement
autre qu'on peut même pas établir de
points de contact
c'est comme vouloir expliquer le passage
d'une banane à la liberté
ça n'a pas de sens
et c'est ce qui fait que quand on change
de paradigme on peut pas dire
rigoureusement parlant ce qui était vrai
et ce qui était faux dans l'ancien
paradigme
parce qu'un paradigme ça ne se découpe
pas
on peut pas le fractionner
il faut penser la notion de paradigme en
terme de regard
c'est le regard qui change
et quand le regard change tout change
vous souvenez de cette scène du film Le
Cercle des poètes disparus
quand Robin Williams monte sur son
bureau
et qu'il encourage ses élèves en faire
de même pour je cite ne pas oublier
qu'on doit s'obliger sans cesse à tout
regarder sous un angle différent
c'est ça changer de paradigme
changer son angle de perception
et dès lors qu'on change son angle de
perception on voit un monde différent
notre univers mental se transforme
l'empathie la véritable empathie pas
simplement le transfert de son point de
vue sur l'autre
la véritable empathie c'est adopter le
point de vue de l'autre
c'est ce glisser dans sa peau c'est
épouser son âme et sa rétine
c'est difficile
les fondamentalement c'est ça
alors Thomas schoon ne dit pas que
science égale empathique mais dit que la
modification du regard est un élément
constitutif de la science
il dit que la science ne peut progresser
qu'à la condition d'un basculement
permanent de sa perspective
et que la production scientifique est
tributaire d'un contexte
d'un contexte psychologique d'un
contexte cognitif et même d'un contexte
social
un paradigme c'est tout ça à la fois
par exemple coup n'explique que les
jeunes chercheurs parce qu'ils sont
installés depuis moins longtemps dans un
paradigme auront plus facilement
tendance à souligner ses failles
en voir les limites
et que donc les jeunes chercheurs sont
sociologiquement plus disposés à initier
un changement de paradigme
ça paraît idiot mais quand on y
réfléchit ça a du sens
effectivement quand on est habitué à un
modèle quand on y est confortablement
installé
on a moins tendance à vouloir en changer
et la communauté scientifique ça reste
des êtres humains
des êtres humains soumis au même biais
et aux mêmes influences que les autres
donc Kun tient compte dans son analyse
de la dimension psychosociale de la
recherche
du fait que les chercheurs sont des
êtres incarnés
et que la force d'un paradigme tient
aussi à la force avec laquelle on
cherche à le maintenir
ce n'est pas seulement l'échec du
paradigme qui détermine son remplacement
c'est d'abord la constatation de cet
échec
la science c'est comme les accidents de
voiture
s'il n'y a pas de constat il n'y a pas
eu d'accident
c'est la science rencontre un problème
mais que la majorité des scientifiques
préfèrent minimiser l'importance de ce
problème
voire ne pas le considérer comme un vrai
la révolution mettra du temps à arriver
proposer un modèle alternatif
socialement c'est pas toujours évident
tant qu'une idée nouvelle n'est pas
admise elle est rejetée
autrement dit il y a aussi dans la
pratique sociale de la science un
conformisme
remettre en cause un modèle
c'est remettre en cause la norme
et remettre en cause la norme c'est
remettre en cause tout un appareil
social
toute une autorité sociale
l'idée d'une communauté scientifique
imperméable et insensible aux
déterminants humains c'est très naïf
et c'est même assez dangereux parce que
ça pousse à croire que la parole des
scientifiques vaut comme parole
d'évangile
ceux contre quoi Kun nous met en garde
c'est l'absolutilisation du discours
scientifique
absolutisation qui mène à la
sacralisation
non les savoirs scientifiques ne sont
pas gravés dans le marbre
ils ne sont pas des vérités intangibles
ils sont des vérités provisoires
des vérités jusqu'à ce qu'on change de
paradigme
et dire ça ce n'est pas faire un jeu à
la science
ce n'est pas dire la science raconte
n'importe quoi
ni même la science se trompe
parce que pour pouvoir dire la science
se trompe encore faut-il avoir défini
une vérité par rapport à laquelle elle
se trompe
dire la science se trompe c'est dire il
existe des vérités intangibles
lorsque nous dit Thomas Coon c'est
justement que l'ambition d'atteindre une
vérité intangible en science n'a pas de
sens
puisqu'on se situe toujours dans un
certain paradigme qui en tant que tel
possède ses limites et c'est lacunes
en science il n'y a pas de point de vue
omniscient
il n'y a pas de point de vue neutre ou
objectif
il n'y a que des modèles normatifs
il n'y a que des angles de vue
et encore une fois c'est pas un problème
on demande pas la science de tout
expliquer
on demande à la science de progresser
et pour Kun le progrès des sciences ne
consiste pas dans une augmentation
indéfinie des connaissances
il consiste dans un mouvement permanent
dans un déplacement permanent d'un
paradigme un autre à chaque fois que le
paradigme vigueur montre ses limites
ce n'est pas parce que la science ne
peut pas atteindre la vérité absolue
qu'elle n'est pas bénéfique
elle est bénéfique à la compréhension
elle est bénéfique aux découvertes et
elle est bénéfique dans ses applications
si les savoirs scientifiques n'étaient
seulement qu'un ramassis de croyances on
aurait pas internet
on ne prendrait pas l'avion
il faut bien que la science est comprise
deux trois trucs sur le fonctionnement
de l'univers pour qu'un avion décolle
donc la relativité des savoirs
scientifiques ne remet pas en cause
l'utilité des savoirs scientifiques
elle est remet simplement en perspective
alors effectivement il y a dans le
lexique scientifique des mots qui nous
induisent en erreur
et qui nous font croire que la science a
bel et bien une prétention absolue
par exemple le fait de parler de loi
physique ou de loi astronomiques
ça donne une impression d'intangibilité
et donc quand cette intangibilité
commence à s'affaisser autrement dit
quand on commence à s'apercevoir qu'une
théorie scientifique est finalement
peut-être invalide parce qu'elle ne
cadre plus avec les données observables
on sait qu'il va falloir remplacer le
paradigme
et donc admettre que jusqu'à aujourd'hui
on était dans l'erreur
qu'on était sûr et certain que ce modèle
était le bon parce qu'il fonctionnait et
que maintenant il ne fonctionne plus
c'est difficile
imaginez on étudie un phénomène on
arrive à trouver une loi qui explique ce
phénomène on utilise cette loi on crée
des applications à partir de cette loi
bref elle fonctionne
et un beau jour on se rend compte qu'en
fait non
la loi n'était pas bonne
parce qu'on vient de rencontrer un
phénomène qui ne cadre pas avec cette
loi
c'est ce qui s'est passé avec Galilée
avant Galilée on pensait que la vitesse
à laquelle un corps chute dépendait de
sa masse
que plus un objet était lourd et plus il
tombe vite
Galilée a démontré qu'en fait non
la masse n'a pas d'incidence sur la
vitesse de la chute
parce que l'inertie et l'attraction se
compensent
donc avant que Galilée cette loi en
fonctionnait sur un modèle faux
un modèle faux mais qui fonctionnait
suffisamment pour qu'on n'ait pas besoin
de le remplacer
croire que les objets tombent à des
vitesses différentes selon leur masse
jusqu'au 17e siècle ça n'entravait pas
la recherche
ça n'entravait pas l'explication des
phénomènes physiques
pour qu'un savoir soit remis en cause il
faut que son caractère faux ou que son
caractère incomplet produisent des
anomalies pratiques
il faut que son caractère faux se
remarque
sinon il n'y a pas de raison de le
corriger
puisqu'on ne voit pas qu'il est faux
c'est ça que nous dit que
la remise en cause d'un savoir est
toujours le fruit d'une anomalie dans la
pratique
un empêchement d'un obstacle
et l'observation d'une anomalie va
initier l'entrée dans une période que
Kun va appeler une crise
la science est faite de crise
et ses crises ne sont pas en soi
négatives
elles sont négatives du point de vue de
la communauté scientifique qui vit une
crise qui voit toutes ces certitudes
volées en éclat
qui se dit que c'est pas possible
d'avoir plus aussi longtemps quelque
chose qui en réalité était faux
mais du point de vue de l'histoire des
sciences ces crises sont positives
parce que quand une crise se produit ça
veut dire qu'il va falloir s'activer les
neurones pour trouver une explication
une crise ça oblige la communauté
scientifique à innover
à innover pour résoudre l'anomalie et
ainsi surmonter la crise
la science est fondamentalement
dialectique
elle convertit des anomalies en progrès
la crise c'est le moteur du progrès
scientifique
donc selon Kun la science n'est jamais
autant la science que quand elle est
face à une crise
quand elle est face à un ensemble
d'anomalies qui vont la contraindre à
changer de modèle
je dis bien changer de modèle et non pas
changé le modèle
puisque quand on modifie un modèle quand
on modifie un système c'est tout le
système qui se modifie
un système n'est un système que parce
qu'il y a interdépendance des éléments
qui le constituent
un élément qui change et c'est tout le
système qui saute
donc quand il y a anomalie que ces
anomalies persistent au point de
produire une crise
le paradigme vigueur est obligé
d'appliquer
il sera remplacé par un nouveau
paradigme
c'est ça que thomascon appelle la
structure des révolutions scientifiques
on a un modèle ce modèle fonctionne
c'est-à-dire il permet de produire de la
connaissance
il permet de résoudre des énigmes de
faire des découvertes et puis un jour
problème
une anomalie
le modèle search a une incompréhension
à une incompréhension structurelle
c'est la crise
des modèles alternatifs font leur
apparition
ils entrent en concurrence les uns avec
les autres jusqu'à ce qu'un de ces
modèles alternatifs réussissent à
résoudre les anomalies
à ce moment là le modèle alternatif
devient le nouveau modèle dominant
il devient le nouveau paradigme
une révolution scientifique c'est quand
une ancienne conception est révolue
c'est à dire qu'elle génère trop
d'anomalies pour pouvoir être conservé
quand un modèle est révolu il y a révolu
Sion
donc on remplace le modèle par un
nouveau modèle plus complet
et une fois installé dans ce nouveau
modèle on recommence
on recommence c'est à dire on reprend la
recherche
et on va découvrir et expliquer tout un
tas de choses aussi longtemps qu'on ne
rencontrera pas d'anomalie
c'est ce que cool appelle la science
normale
la science normale c'est la science
normée
la science sur ses rails
ou tout fonctionne
où tout est conforme aux prédictions
et puis un beau jour aïe une anomalie
un imprévu
le modèle présente une faille
il est fissuré
et un modèle qui se fissure ce n'est pas
un modèle qu'on va réparer
on va pas colmater
on va au contraire creuser la fissure
élargir la fissure
jusqu'à ce que le modèle s'effondre afin
de pouvoir remplacer le modèle
c'est ça pour Thomas Coon l'histoire des
sciences
une alternance de moments productifs et
de moments critiques
la science normale et la science
révolutionnaire
et quand la science est en crise c'est
que tout va bien
c'est que tout va bien parce que ça veut
dire que la science va bientôt connaître
une révolution
et qu'on entrera bientôt dans une aire
de renouvellement des connaissances
je cite
les révolutions politiques commencent
par le sentiment croissant parfois
restreint à une fraction de la
communauté politique que les
institutions existantes ont cessé de
répondre d'une manière adéquate au
problème posé par un environnement
qu'elles ont contribué à créer de
semblables manières les révolutions
scientifiques commencent avec le
sentiment croissant souvent restreint à
une petite fraction de la communauté
scientifique qu'un paradigme a cessé de
fonctionner de manière satisfaisante
pour l'exploration d'un aspect de la
nature sur lequel ce même paradigme a
antérieurement dirigé les recherches
dans le développement politique comme
dans celui des sciences le sentiment
d'un fonctionnement défectueux
susceptible d’aboutir à une crise et la
condition indispensable des révolutions
nous nous proposons de démontrer que
dans l'évolution des sciences l'étude
historique du changement de paradigme
révèle des caractéristiques tout à fait
semblables comme le choix entre des
institutions politiques concurrentes
celui qui doit s'effectuer entre des
paradigmes concur s'avère être un choix
entre des modes de vie de la communauté
qui sont incompatibles de ce fait il est
impossible que ce choix soit déterminé
simplement par des procédés d'évaluation
qui caractérisent la science normale
puisque ceci dépendent en partie d'un
paradigme particulier lequel précisément
est mis en question quand les paradigmes
entre ce qui arrive forcément dans une
discussion sur le choix du paradigme
leur rôle est nécessairement circulaire
chaque groupe se sert de son propre
paradigme pour épuiser ses arguments de
défense le savant qui s'efforce de
résoudre un problème défini par le
savoir et les techniques existants ne
cherchent pas simplement au hasard
autour de lui il sait ce qu'il veut
réaliser il conçoit son appareillage et
oriente ses réflexions en conséquence
une nouveauté inattendue une découverte
nouvelle ne peuvent apparaître que dans
la mesure où ce qu'il attend de la
nature et de ses instruments se trouve
démenti et l'importance de la découverte
qui adulte sera souvent proportionnelle
à l'étendue et à la ténacité de
l'anomalie qu'il a annoncé donc de toute
évidence il faut bien qu'il y ait
conflit entre le paradisme qui a permis
d'apercevoir l'anomalie et celui qui
fera d'elle un phénomène conforme à la
loi les exemples de découvertes
accompagnés
ce qu'il faut retenir de tout ce que
nous dit Thomas
c'est qu'en matière de connaissance
augmentation n'est pas toujours synonyme
de progrès
la science ne progresse pas forcément en
augmentant ses connaissances
elle progresse aussi quand elle
rencontre une limite
quand elle est en échec
quand elle s'aperçoit et surtout quand
elle admet que ce qu'elle croyait vrai
ne l'était en réalité pas tout à fait
c'est là que tout se joue
être capable de remise en cause
être capable de cette humilité qui fait
que lorsqu'on s'aperçoit qu'on s'est
trompé
on en fait pas une affaire personnelle
parce que ça arrive
et que l'erreur comme la science
et humaine
l'histoire des sciences n'est pas une
flèche
ce sont des boucles
l'histoire des sciences avancent
mais elle n'avance que par des
mouvements de retour sur elle-même
elle n'avance quand rebroussant
constamment son propre chemin
grâce aux crises qu'elle rencontre et
qu'il oblige à devenir une meilleure
version d'elle-même
la crise qui conclut un cycle
en même temps quelle ligne ici un
nouveau cycle
au fond la science est comme l'être
humain
elle a besoin de chuter
pour pouvoir mieux se relever
je vous remercie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]